OK. Let's go to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3 0
forty 750. I'm curious. I have a guy from
the ATO five who previously called me from
a city bus. I want to pick up on him to see
where where he is today. Guy from 8 0 5. Are
you with me?
Yes, I am. Hey, where are you calling from
today? I'm calling from not a city bus, which
is optimal. Sorry, that last time I I was.
I called you from a bus that was very stable
and it was like a long distance bus. And right.
If you picked up, I had I was like in a transfer
and everything kind of went sideways. Very
good. All right.
Very good. Well, I'm glad to hear from you.
What's on your mind today?
So as I am. Oh, no.
Bernie Sanders just dropped off, dropped out
of the Democratic presidential primary. I
was wondering. Like, I don't know where do
we go from that, like, what is the future
of the progressive movements?
Well, listen.
You're doing so for whatever reason, we're
still having connection issues with you today.
But certainly we can't attribute it to the
bus here. Here's my sense. I think that right
now we need to as the progressive. Oh, boy.
All right. I'm in. I'm going to have to let
you go and I'll answer off line. Here's my
thought. We have to balance wanting progressive
successes today with the fact that if Donald
Trump gets reelected, the country is going
to be further harmed for an additional four
years. And I cannot take any action that will
make that more likely to happen. So unfortunately,
and this is a tough pill to swallow for a
lot of people. I believe we need to make sure
Joe Biden is the next president of the United
States. I actually believe that unless we
do that, the progressive movement will get
nothing done for the next four years as opposed
to getting some small things done over the
next at least two years and then maybe more
depending on what happens in the Senate in
twenty, twenty two. That's my view. And I
know it's too centrist for some people, it's
too pragmatic. For some people. It's not visionary
enough for some people. But I can assure you,
if Trump gets another four years, we're gonna
go in the opposite direction for those four
years and it'll be a very, very bad thing